fahren recorder ultra auch noch in 1080p
weitwinkel für neun euro für 1 euro ach
nee das ein schlüsselanhänger
hey leute was darf man jetzt willkommen
beim ein video
ja ich habe wieder kurze haare ich war
heute nach gefühlten zehn jahren endlich
mal wieder beim friseur und diese ganze
menüs abgekommen ich bin ich zufrieden
eigentlich darum soll es heute aber gar
nicht gehen und zwar ist heute wirklich
der erste tag an dem ich nur gedacht
habe du machst einfach mal zwei videos
an einem tag das ding ist ich hab mir
gerade noch ziemlich viel frei und bevor
ich jetzt einfach rumhänge kann ich auch
noch das video abdrehen weil ich das eh
schon längst machen wollte auf jeden
fall steht unter jedem 100% zufällig
bestellen wieder drunter jo alex
bestellt doch bitte auch mal auf jugend
da soll das extrem günstig sein der
versand ist kostenlos und ich habe von
dieser seite vorher noch nie gehört aber
ich habe mir die gerade mal angeschaut
und ich würde sagen es waren heute
einfach mal ich weiß nicht ob viele von
euch die seite kennen sollten aber an
sich ist auch egal ihr kennt sie ja
spätestens jetzt oder gleich und ich
würde sagen will aber gar nicht lange
und fangen sofort mahnt bei 10.000 sechs
bestellen wir noch mal auf jugend boom
boom so leute wir sind jetzt hier auf
der startseite der website google.com.hk
nicht ist wahrscheinlich auch ich glaube
das sind auch alles sachen aus china ist
es ein bisschen aufgebaut wie wish das
sieht man hier schon auch vom preis her
40 stück auto datenkabel krawatte kabel
montiert das habe ich schon immer
gesucht werden oder wir haben hier den
deal der stunde
123 mm flache nudel micro usb ladegeräte
und natürlich werde ich am ende auch
wieder einige sachen bestellen und ihren
halt testen wenn sie irgendwann mal
ankommen sollten ich habe heute leider
keine nette assistentin hinter der
kamera die den zufallsgenerator für mich
macht deswegen muss ich das selber
machen aber das gar nicht so schlimm und
zwar zeige ich euch was ich vorhabe wir
haben ja ganz viele verschiedene
kategorien an der seite und wir dürfen
jetzt einfach mal die 12 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 uhren haben wir ja noch gar
keine
und hier holen wir uns die 71 23
3 4 5 6 7 taschen ketten uhren fuß
wieder unterkategorien gibt's denn da
und jetzt die acht als wir drei vier
fünf sechs sieben acht kinder uhren und
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wir haben
hier die 16 48 12 16
nur für 1 euro alles klar geil ihr könnt
mir doch jetzt nicht erzählen dass diese
uhr wirklich funktioniert sogar mit
taschenrechner leute ich hab ja letztens
diese vision getestet vor zwei oder drei
tagen und das ist halt dann ausschauen
die uhr nicht bestellt habe wenn
vielleicht auch kurz noch mal eine
nahaufnahme wird sagen wir machen das
ganze jetzt mal auf und haben dann hier
die ruhe und die ab 15 euro kostet die
war auch echt qualitativ in ordnung was
das jetzt ist da bin ich gespannt
ja komm wir nehmen die farbe schwarz in
den einkaufswagen und damit schon die
uhr drinnen okay also das prinzip sollte
alle verstanden haben wir haben jetzt
hier die neuen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 koffer
und taschen und hier haben wir die elw 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
scheiße hier haben wir die 5 1 2 3 4 5
herren taschen passt ja gut hier haben
wir die 5 1 2 3 4 5 und die haben wir
jetzt schon sachen und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt 11 48 19 11 2 euro also wenn
jetzt hier der versand auch noch
kostenfrei ist das rechnet sich doch gar
nicht wenn ich jetzt diese tasche
bestelle und die aus china kommt die
kostet zwei euro
der versand wird für das unternehmen die
tasche herstellt und verschickt
garantiert vier euro sein
wenn ich sogar mehr als gut wir nehmen
die in rotbraun und in den einkaufswagen
das ist einfach so unbequem hier zu
sitzen so okay wir machen weiter wir
haben hier die neuen schon wieder die
neuen in das hat
wir haben hier die 81 unter koffer und
taschen autos jetzt finde ich mal
gespannt und die 212 innenausstattung
ihren wir die 31 23 halter und ständer
ok und die fünf kann ich jetzt nicht
zählen doch charakter wird ihr gebt mir
eine 59 14 12 14 mehrzweck auto cup
alter lagerung halter handyhalter so
habe ich den einkaufswagen gehauen
wir machen schnell weiter ich werde zwar
irgendwas richtig krasses regeln was
mich überrascht das sind ja alles gerade
sachen die ganz cool sind so aber so
wirklich brauchen tut man das alles
nicht mehr auch wenn es echt günstig ist
davon bin ich echt beeindruckt viele
letzten minuten runter geschrieben ja
alex euro ist alles so günstig weil das
natürlich zu geringen preisen
hergestellt wird man hat ja auf dieses
vorurteil dass in china oder keine
ahnung wann hat ist jetzt speziell die
umstände für arbeiter nicht immer gut
sind und deshalb auch kinderarbeit gibt
das ist für mich eine sache das kann auf
jeden fall sein
ich finde man kann es aber nie genau
sagen es gibt auch so viele große
unternehmen von denen ich ganz genau
weiß dass halt auch außerhalb von
deutschland jetzt die produkte in nicht
so wirklich optimal umstellen jahr
produziert werden und deswegen wäre da
vorsichtig zu sagen ja alles
kinderarbeit oder das hier ist jetzt
alles kinderarbeit ja ist natürlich sehr
schade dass man es eigentlich nie genau
weiß so wir machen weiter und würfeln
hier die 14 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 kameras und optiken und die 5
12345 auto kamera geil und die 2 auto.de
wie er das so leute ich musste mal
koalitionen hinsetzen weil mein fuß
eingeschlafen ist wir haben jetzt diese
ganzen kameras und ich muss sagen ich
habe mir echt schon öfter mal überlegt
mir so eine kamera anzuschaffen
einfach weil ich so oft im
straßenverkehr irgendwelche vollidioten
vor mir habe oder irgendwas sehe was man
dann so gerne mal auf kamerad und das um
das in erster linie freunden zu zeigen
aber vielleicht auch mal zur polizei zu
schicken weil es wirklich solche witze
auf den straßen gibt es ist unglaublich
wie rücksichtslos manche menschen fahren
so jetzt bin ich vom thema abgeschweift
und wir haben ja die 26 34 5 das kann
doch nicht nur einen euro kosten fahren
recorder ultra auch noch in 1080p
weitwinkel
für neun euro notfallspeichern
funktionen schlüssel wichtige dateien zu
sperren also wenn das jetzt wirklich
eine kamera ist die funktioniert also
dann bin ich echt erstaunt gehauen dass
in den einkaufswagen so also auf die
auto kamera bin ich echt gespannt wenn
die ankommt und ich würde sagen drei
sachen gehen noch wir fangen jahren mit
der 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 juwelierwaren die 8
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 piercing
achso hier haben wir schon 14 kommen und
die 4 1 2 3 4
ich hatte also ich bin piercings zum
teil echt nicht schön und wenn ich dann
so ein sehr dafür habe ich null
verständnis so ein hässliches herz auf
der nase zu tragen das würde ich auch
nicht haben
ich würde echt gerne andere kategorie
auswählen wir haben jetzt hier die 5 1
345 ringe ja und wir nehmen hier die
fünf 12345 tollen ring geil guck mal ich
habe jetzt fünf produkte hier drin und
zahl 35 euro versand kostenlos nur die
produkte kosten 19 euro
achso eigentlich führen sie 35 kosten da
der versand aber kostenlos ist
20 19 also 19 euro für diese sachen das
ist eine ansage
da kann auch ruhig einfangen okay leute
wir haben hier die 31 23 elektronik und
jetzt bin ich echt mal gespannt wie
teuer hier so einen computer oder keine
ahnung wir schauen einfach mal was wir
bekommen die fünf und wir haben ja jetzt
die 212 telefone und kommunikation also
jetzt muss ich wirklich mal kurz die ins
ins handy und smartphone links gehen
weil die wir sind jetzt hier im handy
und smartphone zu gehören gehen in die
eins zwei drei vier fünf lautsprecher
und die fünf lautsprecher für fünf euro
in pinker also wie schon gesagt wo ich
finde ich extrem günstig aber dann kann
ich noch verstehen dass ich das
vielleicht so ein bisschen rechnet nur
wie sich jung rechnet dass die halt
wirklich gewinn machen einmal die seite
und auch die hersteller das weiß ich
nicht aber gut so ich würde sagen wir
machen weiter und zwar mit der einst im
haushalt und wohnen okay ich bin gerade
überlegen was glaubt ihr wird gibt es
mehr auch ruhig oder auf juden also
welche seite hat wohl ein größeres
sortiment ich muss aber sagen dass ich
mit diesen sachen hier auf jugendlich so
zufrieden bin da habe ich auch nicht
viel kleinere sachen gefunden deswegen
bevor ich es ihm
müll bestelle der auch 0 interessant ist
probieren wir einfach mal irgendwelche
wörter aus die schon mal benutzt habe
für meine anderen video wie hält zum
beispiel wie zum beispiel handy was da
kommt wie erwartet sind handy hüllen
oder ladekabel diese gab es auf wunsch
das ist ja auch gut nur ist lenkt halt
auch noch mal ein bisschen ab und dann
kann ich sehen wie schnell man ist aber
an sich finde ich diese idee halt als
navi dann sehr gut nur brauche ich nicht
okay ich gebe dann einfach nochmal
stream ein wir bestellen einfach mal die
4 1 234 oberkleidung herren skateboard
sweatshirt jacke trug was hat das jetzt
mit so herter das obwohl das finde ich
cool aus ja wenn ich mal gespannt also
da bin ich gespannt was ankommt so in
den einkaufswagen in rot geile stream
also so interessant es echt nicht aber
eine sache geht noch die 15 10 11 13 14
15 schuhe und die 313 euro männerschuhe
und hier haben wir die einst turnschuhe
[Musik]
für einen euro ach nee das ist ein
schlüsselanhänger
ich dachte schon okay leute die sechs
der das sind ja sogar die idee ins alter
garnier sie schlüsselanhänger ich finde
aber eigentlich dass hier am besten
deswegen nehmen wir auch die in den
einkauf hier jetzt habe ich andere egal
so leute also wenn wir jetzt mal schauen
wir haben acht produkte drin insgesamt
für 44 euro einmal den jesus oder länger
den supreme wurde welcher keiner ist den
lautsprecher den ring die auto kamera
die ich echt cool findet dieses ding was
eigentlich kein mensch braucht die
tasche für zwei euro und die hohe für 1
euro und ja nicht schlecht und das ganze
sollte bis zum 20
da sein also ich bin gespannt am meisten
freue ich mich aber eigentlich auch das
wahrscheinlich das kommt jetzt nächste
woche auf jeden fall haben wir das volk
all handy sehr bekannte marke
ich hoffe dass wir dadurch gefallen bei
10.000 machen wir nochmal jugend und 36
eine beinah